woher kommt der große rote fleck warum
wird eher kleiner warum existiert ja
schon so lange der jupiter stellt uns
vor große rätsel und jetzt ist noch
eines hinzu gekommen seine polarlichter
sie sind einfach riesenhaft und
rekordverdächtig jetzt hat ein
forschungsteam eine wirklich mysteriöse
entdeckung gemacht die die polarlichter
des jupiter südpols betrifft
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit sind baff die aktuelle
entdeckung gibt große rätsel auf welches
verhalten der polarlichter so mysteriös
und warum es bislang gängige theorien
komplett auf den kopf stellt jetzt den
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
wir haben ja schon öfter mal über den
riesenplaneten jupiter berichtet der uns
immer mal wieder vor große rätsel stellt
fest steht er ist wohl vom stärksten
planetaren magnetfeld des sonnensystems
umgeben das sorgt zum beispiel dafür
dass seine polarlichter sehr lebhaft und
dynamisch sind seine augen leuchten vor
allem im ultravioletten im sichtbaren
licht sind sehr unauffällig entdeckt
wurden sie im jahr 1979 von der us
raumsonde voyager 1 dennoch wusste waren
lange nur wie die autoren der
nordpolarregion aussehen denn die sind
von der erde aus tatsächlich sichtbar
doch unser unwissen über den südpol des
jupiters hat die nasa raumsonde juno
beseitigt sie war im august 2011
gestartet und waren juli 2016 in die
umlaufbahn des jupiters eingeschränkt
seitdem hat sie beispielsweise infrarot
aufnahmen von seinem nord und südpol
gemacht und ihre messungen haben uns zum
ersten mal auch die polarlichter an
seinem südpol offenbart sie enthüllten
tatsächlich erstaunliches die
energiereichen teilchen ströme und das
magnetfeld verhalten sich komplett
anders als bei den polarlichtern der
erde jetzt kommt eine weitere wirklich
mysteriöse erkenntnis hinzu ein
forschungsteam aus london hat die beiden
weltraumteleskope xmm newton und shanda
genutzt und den südpol von jupiter
mehrere tage lang mit diesen beiden
röntgenteleskop beobachtet das ergebnis
auch hier gibt es ähnlich wie am nordpol
ein gebiet in dem sich die
röntgenstrahlung der polarlichter
konzentriert und das in einer mehr als
beeindruckenden größe der jetzt
entdeckte hotspot ist größer als die
gesamte erde war und auch so lager
dieses gebiets hat das forschungsteam
erkenntnisse gewinnen können
es liegt jeweils pohl werz von dem
leuchtenden oval dass die im uv-licht
sichtbaren polarlichter bildet hinzu
kommt eine weitere riesige überraschung
denn das verhalten der jupiter
polarlichter von nord- und südpol
das ist komplett unterschiedlich einen
großen unterschied macht ihre taktung
statt wie erwartet im selben takt zu
pulsieren pulsieren sie völlig
unabhängig voneinander die südliche
röntgen aurora pulsiert in einem elf
minuten zyklus die messungen am nordpol
dagegen ergaben dass die
röntgenstrahlung dort entweder
unregelmäßig auf strahlt oder aber in
einem fünf bis acht
minuten takt pulsiert also deutlich
schneller als bei dem hotspot am jupiter
südpol und das kommt wirklich mehr als
überraschend und setzt die
forschungsteams vor ein großes rätsel
zitat wir dachten dass die aktivität der
beiden voller licht gebiet durch das
magnetfeld des planeten koordiniert wird
sagt eine beteiligten forscher william
dann zudem unterscheiden sich auch die
licht kurven der strahlung so das
ergebnis der aktuellen studie nun gilt
es die ursachen für diese rohren rätsel
zu finden denn bisher galten die
wechselwirkung des sonnenwinds mit dem
jupiter magnetfeld als auslöser der
röntgenstrahlung und zwar in kombination
mit den schwefel und sauerstoff ionen
die vom drittgrößten jupitermond io in
die obere atmosphäre des jupiters gelang
durch sein globales magnetfeld nahm man
bislang an dass die reaktionen dieses
feldes koordiniert ablaufen das
forschungsteam vermutet jetzt dass noch
weitere einflüsse an beiden polen würden
die bislang aber noch unbekannt sind
zitat wir müssen dies weiter untersuchen
um herauszufinden wie der jupiter seine
röntgen aurora produziert betont dann
große hoffnungen setzt das team dabei
auf die messdaten der raumsonde juno
wenn ihr erfahren wollt wie es da
weitergeht und welche neuen erkenntnisse
gibt und auch zu allen anderen themen
die videos nicht verpassen wollte dann
würden wir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesslich den genau auf die glocke
denn dann kriegt er nur mit wenn neue
videos online gehen hier geht es weiter
mit jupiter fakten mit zahlreichen infos
und spektakulären aufnahmen des größten
planeten unseres sonnensystems und
ansonsten bis dann bleib dran